time does change how you feel about
things I will not regret if this is the
last year of pumpkin season Tori Roloff
hints that she and her husband to Zach
Roloff are leaving
ball big war
you make decisions based on your family
and no one else and that's what's
important your focus definitely changes
once you have kids yeah yeah Tory hosted
a q a on Instagram Wednesday and when a
fan asked how much longer they plan to
be on TV the reality star didn't hold
back quote I think our time is
definitely coming to a close but we're
trying to enjoy it while it's here the
Glory Days when we met when it was all
of our friends yeah
at all that was 12 years ago actually
you got to take yourself out of that
situation it's not a family business
you've made it pretty clear it's my way
the highway eventually you've got to cut
the cord and say enough's enough for
your own mental health and your own
family health the mom of three
reportedly added that their decision to
possibly walk away has a lot to do with
all the misconceptions people have of us
and our family because they only get to
see what TLC shows them
et's reached out to TLC the network
that's aired Little People Big World
since its debut in 2006 for comment like
we're so detached from it at this point
that we're just kind of
done but this isn't the first time Tori
has suggested they might be making an
exit from the show that put them on the
map in another q a back in November a
fan asked whether Tori would ever step
away from filming her response yes it's
like normal to only see your family at
like birthdays and Christmas I don't
always have to be best friends Little
People Big World premiered nearly two
decades ago and Zach is the only
remaining child of Matt and Amy Roloff
that's still on the show his siblings
Molly Jacob and Jeremy have all stepped
away over the years and Matt and Amy
divorced in 2016. well why is he just
sitting here because I I'm like 6 30 I
was told it was dinner you know what
shove it up
meanwhile there's been some major
tension between Zach and his dad in
recent seasons of the show after Matt
listed a portion of his Oregon farm up
for sale in May something Zach was
interested in buying Matt Lane decided
against selling it opting instead to
turn it into a short-term vacation
rental the farm is not
like a place of joy for me anymore do
you still feel that way or are things
moving in a direction of healing
it's sad it's like a death in the family
I kind of grieved that
process of letting it go and just moving
on and you know unfortunately I think
it's probably for me been tainted for
ever but you know we'll always have our
memories and nothing can change that E.T
spoke with a couple at the family farm
in October where they opened up about
the drama and how they're working
towards better days I think a lot has
happened it's going to take a long time
I think it's presented a good
opportunity though for all of us to kind
of step back and just remember that
we're family and that's all that truly
matters and you know putting our
businesses and things aside for one
another I feel like the most important
thing yeah
foreign